and I went to repeat welcome to this
video playing this one 64 I think I
flicked a banker against him before
don't quite know what I have this
feeling check and then check its plate
to misplace them white Bishop him but
Bishop is also misplaced head
immediately and will be rebooted shortly
yeah you normally go each five in such a
position I just wonder i can probably i
should probably prepare it there's also
a 6 button I'm a friend of doing this
the Queen side is closed and now we
should see 828 I can get many pieces
over to the Kings side ok night h 5 SB
should be too ok but as five local bit
weakening at the moment still
[Music]
please have to do it not a huge fan of
this position that doesn't look great I
would absolutely like to play a five but
stuff to do that can I need I need to
get rid of pieces here this should age
39 h5 trying to trade something and them
[Music]
[Music]
covering at 75 is something that would
help but I don't know if I can do it
maybe this and then at five look
extremely em they they look off those
pieces of it 12 it's really not good at
all f5 this inside
maybe cuddle here and then play em and
hive on m5v 85 and I cannot allow that
oh yeah of queen is seven it doesn't do
much admittedly it should be to us from
these at the end yeah but now at five is
possible right the cooks may be okay and
still have my doubts them but that 21
Queen f3 does not look like it was the
critical continuation
okay i think i'm getting somewhere
[Music]
Knight f6 I guess or I also have night 2
g-3 jumping in here I don't know whether
what what that leads to more fan of
centralization I think you will go back
to have three and then queen Iain I've
got the e-file all of the Sun what is he
thinking about okay Queenie 3 f 94 as
well that is actually awkward very
awkward and 1h 3 so on Queen D 1 i've
got 93 so okay he's longer thought yeah
given gives me the time to figure out
that i'm actually already winning yeah i
think you know the last couple of movie
played a little bit weird i think i had
a pretty bad position yeah so here I am
he wants to play the ship and fire so h6
doesn't convince all that much okay to
maybe
I still couldn't move tonight what did I
move the night like to deform there was
a weird decision I mean okay I saw that
this position is good for black and I
didn't try all that hard to improve on
it but still that the other the other
continuation was certainly strong
warning certainly stronger
he has a hard time to cover that
[Music]
don't see how he covers it let it that's
true that's true still not found this
position
right age 65 is my idea up to d4
this guy awkward 94
no defense I thank you check check check
check check check check check check
[Music]
check late okay that was not a good
position I think he but here yet somehow
lost lots of time down and I got to
improve my situation step by step there
is also ethics in this kind of position
maybe this is what I should do next time
I have a wake wake memory that that was
something that we had this on the board
to form check yeah so here I'm just
defending against the e5 IDM i'm not i'm
not sure i felt i didn't do a bad job to
keep things keep things under control
yeah f5 this is a move that he can of
course play i was thinking that night
and 72 here should be ok but this is an
interesting idea of course
looking at this page eight well then why
does definitely better him so maybe as
high for that was the same Queen f2 yeah
that was literal certainly wrong at
Queen Queen f24 we should be to that
looks better why does unquestionably
better in this position right back again
at five yeah I was always relying on
night at seven but this is probably why
it was so reluctant to play it but now
that I got in a fight myself I'm
definitely out of the woods it looks
okay now yeah yeah I missed night here I
can just try another night anyway
because of h3 I was Rookie to was a
stupid idea I don't know what I was
thinking I mean it is just engine wise
and winning as well you know but if you
can take h3 just like that it's a bit
easier check check mad you win ending
they are probably I shouldn't slide 5 so
it may be b6 is more flexible and then
see what to do that with the structure
ok guys thanks for watching